i'm a 25 year old i used to work in
banking at m a i made like low six
figures and it was a cool job but i
recently quit after listening to you
guys and now i own a bunch of vending
machines and it's allowed me to make 10
grand a month and
do a bunch of running and he said quote
do memorable things which is what you
guys talked about at the end of the pod
this is pretty amazing
[Music]
all right i think we're good we good
dude sean thanks for dressing up you
look nice
all right so for those who can't see the
youtube video right now
sam is like in some kind of like uh
i don't even know where he's at he's in
some kind of like la
some kind of playboy mansion podcast
studio i don't even know what's going on
not a single wall is normal one of
them's like a 3d texture one of them's
got like a plant from you know the the
amazon jungle
and
he's got like five people there he's got
like a movie crew somebody just came and
powdered his nose i don't know what's
going on i'm still in my bedroom
and i recently woke up so you know we
got a little yin and yang going
underneath playing what you're wearing
sean
shirtless
if sam sees a shoulder he has like a
minor panic attack
it just uh you know
it's something we can't all dress like
arthur
so
i was hoping that if i came here so i
came here the other day to record a
podcast with this guy named danny and i
came here i go i called ben like right
when i was there i facetime i go ben
book this for like in three days this is
where we're gonna record from now on and
i was like if if we do this here maybe
it would inspire sean to like record
with more than just one airpod in his
iphone and a plant in the background and
maybe we can make something happen so
hopefully i'm gonna wear off on you and
we'll you'll do it right on your end
because i think we'll get more views on
youtube finally
yeah the last time i felt this much peer
pressure i ended up you know on shrooms
and so hopefully this just ends better
but i do feel the pressure now i will
find
you know i don't even know what is this
place that you're at you give them a
shout out what is the name of a place
it's called w say their name but what's
it called wf media
wtw wtf media i can't that guy you know
that guy danny you were on his thing too
he's been emailing me for me oh really
okay cool well i came on his thing and i
came here and it was awesome i think we
paid a couple hundred bucks i don't
remember to be here and i think this is
actually the same studio that andrew
schultz and charlemagne i think record
their thing right
yeah and it's like pretty easy so i just
took you know rode my scooter here
and and did it just like charlemagne the
goddess yeah
all right let's let's uh let's jump into
some stuff you have some topics i got
some topics where do you want to start
we got a bunch of different ways we can
go wait we got to do this uh did you see
this email that i got from this uh
listener
no where okay so i forwarded it to you
so basically uh we were talking about
like adventurous [__] last time and this
guy emailed me and let me pull it up so
basically he said
he goes all right uh you you wrote you
guys talked about like living an
adventurous life i wanted to write you
and fill you in on what's going on i
used to be 230 pounds and like pretty
overweight but then i started running
and i started listening to you guys the
whole entire time while i would run in
fact i did a 50 mile race and i only
listened to mfm the entire time and i've
lost a ton of weight and now next week
i'm doing a 100 mile race and i intend
to listen to you guys the whole time as
well and i'm a 25 year old i used to
work in banking at m a i made like low
six figures and it was a cool job but i
recently quit after listening to you
guys and now i own a bunch of vending
machines and it's allowed me to make 10
grand a month and uh do a bunch of
running and he said quote do memorable
things which is what you guys talked
about at the end of the pod this is
pretty amazing i forward it to you it's
that's a good story right
yeah dude that's my my version of
torture though like having to run 50
miles while listening to my voice in my
head that would be like that would be
like you know worse than waterboarding
for me personally but dude props to this
guy this is amazing uh
you know fitness got influenced by you
listening to the pod got influenced by
both of us you know
did the vending machine side hustle that
we had talked about got to the 10k a
month and now he has the freedom he's
thinking about doing short-term rentals
i think this might be your best friend i
think you might have just found an adult
best friend yeah this is my little
brother man i like this guy his name's
jack so i saw that email and i was like
we gotta bring that up that's a good one
but um this is he ended it with hashtag
do things and i like that i like do
things that's the serious version of no
small boy stuff which is the official
motto of my first million uh very good i
like that all right where do you want to
go john jackson jeff yeah good job jack
jack nermer good job
um
i want to tell you about an idea that i
saw recently i think i'm going to invest
in this
but it's kind of just like one of these
really
low-key doesn't even seem like a
business things but i think it's going
to be kind of big so
have you ever been on youtube
and seen this thumbnail of like this
kind of anime character wearing
headphones and it says lo-fi
chill beats study music have you ever
seen that kill it they have they run it
on live like youtube live and there'll
be hundreds of thousands of people on it
and i think like the other day it like
was paused for like a few minutes or
something like that and it was in the
news right
it got banned and then it got unbanned
after 133 000 people like signed a
petition to be like unban this right now
that's crazy but okay and what about it
so let me tell you about it so lo-fi
basically the channel has 10 million
subscribers it's one of the most like
sort of longest watch time things on
youtube because people will just sit
there for hour hours studying and just
having this as background music they
have a discord of 700 000 people they
have their own talk about
well it's just people that are chilling
there's people that want us people that
are trying to study they're trying to
focus and they just want to be in a
group of other people doing the same
thing it's like a virtual study hall so
this is kind of like an emergent
behavior it's just a thing that started
happening it's not what youtube was
trying to do it wasn't you know some
company that started right away it's
just kind of like this thing that people
wanted like oh you know like i had this
when i was in college my buddy would
it's like oh hand him the aux plug
because his music is good for us to just
chill do nothing too it's not going to
be distracting that sort of thing and he
would kind of be the dj so
this is like a thing now and i found uh
but but it's still like kind of informal
it's on youtube it's not really like
easy to use in that sense like you know
you know you don't know who these other
people are you can't do a private room
that sort of stuff so there's a startup
called studyverse that is trying to do
this what they did was they basically
turned this
into like its own experience so me and
me and ben use this now when we work we
basically go into studyverse
and you go in and there's like a jukebox
basically so you just put on
yeah like chill hip hop style music or
chill electronic style music or whatever
and both people are hearing the same
thing at the same time you could turn
your camera on or off if you want to
just be there
microphone on or off
and uh you could like put your to-do
list there and other people can see it
and as you knock them out it makes a
little sound so you can see other people
knocking off their to-do list
uh there's a little chat and so and you
could just set the background so you
could be like let's just give the yeah
yeah we're working remote we're uh you
know like i'm in this little home office
here nothing too grand but you could
just set the scene like now what if we
were by the beach or what if we were you
know in space or wherever you want so
it's just a cool little product um and
they're going after this use case of
virtual study hall people getting
together to study hang out or work
but it's really around studying i
believe and this is like a big deal
there are millions of students every day
who do this and they do it with
strangers they're not they're not
necessarily hanging out with their
friends they some do but a lot of people
just want to feel like they don't want
to feel kind of alone and bored when
they study and so just having any other
people chatting or they see their screen
names their profile pictures it just
makes them feel less alone when they're
doing it how do you make money i think
this is going to be
big so the lo-fi uh the lo-fi thing on
youtube i don't know if they just run
ads is monetized that way i'm not 100
sure i know they also have like the
music is their own music they have lo-fi
records so it's all copyright free which
is kind of cool
because that would be the other problem
if you try to do this commercially and
um but for these guys i think they'll
probably have some premium version or
some upsell or so i don't know what
they'll do to make money like the main
thing right now is can they get to like
a million students a day who are
studying with this thing which is like
at that point it's pretty valuable
to be the hub where a million students
today are spending like multiple hours
basically
did
they raise money now yeah so so i'm
investing this thing
um you're doing it a lot of time
yeah i'm gonna do it this right it gives
me heavy like twitch vibes in a in a way
where i'm like there's kind of a
behavior that doesn't really make sense
until you start to think about the use
case and like yeah that would be fun
actually but there's thousands of them i
just googled it there's so many of them
well like virtual study halls yeah
yeah there there are i don't think
there's thousands of them there's one
serious competitor that's like been
around for a little while uh i forgot
it's called but they have it together
they're close to that point
yeah i think it's steady together i
think that's the one um they have a
million people in their community
and uh
and so you know these guys are trying to
build like a better user experience than
that uh so this this i think that this
community study together it says that
there's uh 30 34 000 people concurrently
online so at the hustle we are getting
let's say that we are getting two or
three million monthly uniques basically
that means that which is like two to
three million a month is pretty good if
it's the right niche you can make like
you know a million a month off two to
three million people a month if it's the
right one and at any given point we
would have
2 000 people online like it really would
never get maybe occasionally you would
get to three thousand and four thousand
but virtually never and the fact that
this has 33 000 it's pretty insane
yeah that's right now i mean
i don't even know if school i think it's
like still summer for for people that
they're not even like in school right
now and if you are in high school or or
anything else like you're you're
just the middle of the day you can't be
doing this while you're at school so
this is only going to be like college or
summer school right now i bet this
number could be three times as high for
them during like kind of peak seasons um
you know definitely so so i think that's
kind of amazing and you know like
you know whether they sell you know like
little emotes like discord did like
discord makes millions and millions of
dollars off of just their
like their super emoji that you can have
or
you know
yeah that's discord's business model is
you pay six dollars a month or something
like that for discord nitro and all it
gives you is like your your little your
group can have its own emoji like you
can upload your own emoji and you could
use the premium emoji that they have and
uh same thing with twitch like people
subscribe
for five or six bucks a month to a
a twitch channel and like it's not like
they couldn't just watch it for free
they can watch it for free too they do
it to get a little badge that says i'm
i'm a paid like patron of this person's
channel and secondly they get to use the
custom emoji of that channel right
really the only perks like sometimes
it's subscriber only chat but but that's
not usually the case
and so um so yeah i think you could get
pretty big with something like this
but i think it's one of those like
uh
under the radar niches most people don't
even really recognize that this is a
niche so i think there's a cool idea
that's exciting we talked about it
before
um all right let me run something by you
because you you just actually have been
talking about this so check this out so
you know who scott galloway is
of course the uh right so professor
yeah for those who don't know there's a
dude named scott galloway popular on
twitter for making all these like tech
takes and
he gets made fun of for being wrong a
lot but he takes a lot of swings he's
gonna be wrong a lot but basically he
started this company called l2 which i
think he sold for like 200 million bucks
so he's like really successful already
whatever and he's got this new thing
called section 4 which i think is just
like courses but dude check this out so
new york times it said mr galloway who
was already wealthy from selling two
companies and taking a third public also
makes more than five million dollars a
year from speaking gigs he said largely
from corporations and industry groups
that pay him 50 000 a year or 50 000 for
a virtual event and 250 000 for an
international event i should be broken
up he joked which is pretty funny but
that's that's a ridiculous amount of
money for speaking that is huge
how
how does that work because i know that
you were talking about like it has to
all be it has to all work from uh
book sales right
for you know just like being a new york
times best seller
yeah i think it's like a combination
like you just you're in people's face
enough
with like you know
you you sound polished because you know
they have a podcast they have uh he's
got his blog which is pretty famous
he's got he's been he's been doing this
for like he didn't do this forever dude
i feel like this guy's been
publishing content for like 10 15 years
at least something like that dude isn't
it isn't that right he's not like some
some new no he's not he's not just a guy
i mean he's he's he's great you know
he's good and he's hilarious i listened
i was at uh when i was in germany he
spoke he was very good and like i've
hung out with him he's a really nice guy
and his shtick online i don't always
agree with a lot of his takes and i
think that sometimes he's unnecessarily
a hater but
without a doubt incredibly entertaining
when he does talks like he's got a
little bit of like a comedy shtick on
there he's kind of like a little fu and
he like says like hilarious jokes about
him being like old and like bald and
stuff he's hilarious he's good and this
is that but that's so much five million
dollars a year from speaking is like the
equivalent of having like 50 million
dollars five million dollars a year of
income is is is astronomical you know
what i mean
it really is well just it's true it's
like it's funny that it's uh
it like it's funny that you're
absolutely right that is an absurd
number to be making in speaking fees
you're like a pretty good nba player
at that point
yeah exactly but you're just like giving
a presentation on you're using
powerpoint
and often by the way it's the same
presentation it's the same one you can
do it for 15 years
you know what i mean it's like in your
free time a little bit uh this is crazy
it i just i heard that number and i was
like i i couldn't believe it at first
because it is it's an astronomical
number
how much does like david blaine make
because profg is basically like inviting
a magician to your conference it's like
oh here's the entertainment uh we all
know and love this guy scott galloway he
comes on he kind of does his little
routine and he entertains you and like
that's the that's what he's getting paid
for is to be kind of like a name people
recognize adds legitimacy to the event
and um
and you know provide some entertainment
that's not like completely off the wall
circus stuff it's like well this will be
entertaining but it's still relevant but
here's the thing here's the rub
his pod
it gets it's two times the size of ours
so we get like between we get like in
the hundred thousand sometimes more
sometimes a little less uh
range per episode downloads per episode
he's at 250 000.
so in my head or who is it yeah
yeah that i don't know what it's called
but it's like him and kara swisher it's
on
i don't even [__] know what it is
rico it was like recode or whatever
something else and
in my head i'm
thinking
i'll take half that
right i mean we got to be doing this
i'll do you one better
i'll take a third of that
i'll undercut sam
how often do you get asked to do it uh i
don't get asked that often i don't get
asked that often the number is always
good whenever i do get asked i don't get
asked that often
um
and also i'm not really that interested
in doing this because like you know for
this you gotta travel a bunch uh to do
it i think to do it well you gotta
travel a bunch i don't think people
are gonna do it you wouldn't take your
kids with you on like a trip somewhere
not right you don't wanna see kansas
city
[Laughter]
no i do not want to i don't know i want
to take the the phrase take my kids
somewhere is like already you know the
price just went up uh
so so no i wouldn't want to do that now
but yeah later in life yeah that'd be
great so by the way funny you mentioned
scott galloway
there's a couple things people should
know
number one he's very entertaining great
at content number two his business takes
are pretty awful for the most part he's
been wrong famously wrong many many
times in fact somebody created the
the
anti-professor galloway index or
something what's that website called
where it literally just says anytime he
says to buy or sell something if you
just did the exact opposite here's how
you'd be doing it's like he's down
x percent you know s p 500 is up y
percent and this is up like double the s
p 500
outperforms the market
it's the website's bet against the
professor introducing the anti-galloway
index
and what is the stats what does this say
how has he done or how is the thing done
against him
so his worst prediction was that he said
that may
i think he said that like macy's was
gonna like outperform amazon so like not
that good and then he also said that uh
he also said that um
tesla was a bad bet so like i don't know
even know how to use it so let's see
um
since october tells the 19 tech
companies that have
that the professor has predicted would
fail have outperformed the s p and seen
a whopping 61 return so you would have
made 61 exactly
so that's really funny whoever did that
i i do appreciate that uh last thing is
so so i just talked to a guy yesterday
about
this course business so so he's got this
thing section four
and i was like dude how much money does
that make he goes actually i kind of
like
i've been you know i'm in that same dish
so i've been doing research on it here's
what i think
so here's what he thinks he goes
i think section 4 does like 14 million a
year
in revenue they've raised like 37
million dollars
they just did some layoffs because you
know
yeah um
and he's basically like you know that's
an average of a thousand dollars a year
per learner um you know 30 discount
let's say 700 and he has 21 000 people
uh
you know paying paying to learn um
or something like that maybe 2.1 is what
that was supposed to be i'm not sure but
uh but yeah that's kind of like kind of
crazy then he was like you know also
reforge you know reforge it was like the
yeah
section 4 is basically like some
marketing school
dude i would guess that reforge is in
like the 18 to 20 range
for revenue yeah
do you know how much money reforge has
raised
how much i have no idea
if this guy is right reforge has raised
a total of 81 million dollars
which is just kind of absurd for
for what they're doing but they did
acquire
some other marketing training company so
maybe they raised a bunch of money just
to buy something that had like
established revenue and ebitda um
so anyways these little like marketing
schools that people have created like
these can be kind of big like we should
have if we wanted to monetize mfm this
would have been the way to do it it's
just me and you create like our own
marketing school
i'm pretty sure with our audience and
like what we actually like we've
actually done this like we've actually
done marketing to grow our businesses
successfully owned and exited multiple
businesses now uh brought multiple
businesses to this to this like you know
seven eight figure in revenue uh point
like if anybody should be doing this uh
this should be us not not these guys uh
but you know who wants to go do that i
don't know
so let me tell you about something that
i question if i actually want to go do
that but i hear the numbers and they're
amazing
so
uh b2b media so media companies that
make
content for other businesses i was
talking to this guy the other day and
check this out he's got this company
called aging media okay they make
newsletters for nursing homes so i guess
people who own
nursing homes and people who own hospice
hospice care businesses
and it's like i think only three years
old it's or four years old it's not a
very old company but he was telling me
that this year they'd they'll do around
10 million in revenue and like three or
four million in ebitda
and completely bootstrapped and they
have got 40 employees and if you go go
to it's called aging media go to the
website and look at their [__] it is so
simple it's such a straightforward
business
and i see this stuff and i'm like oh man
i could totally do this for x y and z
and that's a small example there's a
bigger example there's this company
called industry dive industry dive was
just acquired like uh
a week ago i think or two weeks ago they
were acquired for 500 million dollars
they do um a hundred and let's see they
were doing
where is it they were doing 110 million
dollars
they're doing 110 million in revenue
with 30 profit 380 employees 53
newsletters across those 53 newsletters
2.5 million uh subs and
pretty straightforward like not
not complicated not necessarily easy but
not complicated straightforward their
content i think it's okay it's just like
it's basically just bullet points it's
an email with bullet points of what's
happening in like the restaurant
industry or whatever but these companies
the bar i think to be good is so low for
b2b media because it's just like you
know like it just mostly all sucks they
like think that like you have to write a
certain way
but in the way they monetize and make
money is so much better than a consumer
media company because if you are a
person who's selling software or
whatever to a hospice care owner like
you you only have a couple places to go
to and one sale gets you you know
hundreds of thousands or maybe even
millions in revenue like a pretty huge
number and so like these guys basically
what they do they have ads on their site
but they do webinars with a sponsor and
like 15 people sign up for the webinar
or the talk it's basically a podcast
just like this but you got to enter your
email to get in they give that email to
the sponsor and that sponsor hopes to go
and email the 10 people that signed up
and uh
like hopefully they buy their [__] and
it's like 20 or 30 or 40 000 to charge
for like getting those 10 30 50 leads
it's crazy the bar's so low
yeah this this thing is crazy they have
um they're big like verticals or it's
like they have waste dive waste dive is
for the waste management industry then
they'll have like for like
pharmaceuticals and then they'll have
finance and then they'll have like you
know these different uh things i think
their biggest ones so marketing dive is
510 subscribers 510 000 subscribers
uh biopharma dive 275 000 subscribers
construction dive 300 000 subscribers hr
dive 455 uh 450 000 subscribers and then
they have just a bunch of others right
utility dive restaurant dive retail dive
is their apps their their biggest ones
700 000 subscribers it's pretty crazy
this is not a media company really like
you know yes they're media company but
like
the game isn't are you good at making
content the game is are you really good
at acquiring users and like acquiring
subscribers in this industry i don't
think you have to be that good if you're
if you're like a d2c dork like you like
you don't have to be that good at this
like because you're already pretty good
at like trying to acquire a user for two
dollars so you can make eight bucks like
you're probably better more skilled
you're just choosing like a less
lucrative game and here's why this is
interesting the guy who started industry
dives named sean
he previously was the president of
another company called fierce markets
and they did this exact same thing but
they did it starting in 2005 or like
2002 and it was literally the same thing
but they just did a different like
slightly different industries it had 1.2
million subs and it sold for hundreds of
millions of dollars the reason why this
is industry interesting interesting is
it's the same [__] over and over and
over again they just like kind of like
have like a dartboard of like boring
[__] and they just like throw a couple
darts and like yeah yeah let's do that
one yeah
yeah like that's i mean
obviously i'm oversimplifying this but
it's incredibly fascinating to me
because the bar is so low to be
uh successful yeah one thing i have
noticed though like so i i agree with
you this is uh one of those blueprints
that's like a good blue really good
blueprints doesn't take like genius
doesn't take
um a ton of luck
and so you know in that sense it's a
good good blueprint to go after
the downside is now that this is like
this game i think was really awesome
like over the last 10 years i think over
the next 10 years that window is closing
the same thing happened at d to c um the
same thing happened to drop shipping the
same thing anytime
anytime the blueprint is easy i think
that when the company sells for 500
million dollars doing something there's
a bunch of sharks like you and i who
hear about this go study their their
blueprint and you get 15 new
like
aggressive people who now know how big
the prize is for something like this and
now have a blueprint to follow all doing
the same thing i still think you could
win and some somebody will win but it is
i would say 10 times harder than it was
over the last 10 years in my opinion
because you're gonna have that set of
people this is exactly what's going on
in d2c which is that
cost of acquiring customers are going up
why because people realized oh you could
just do this with like you know pick a
product run this run this facebook ad
blueprint use shopify use clavio it's
like this stack of like i just need to
do these things so many more people
doing that than this there's so many
more people starting deodorant and like
jewelry brands than there are this board
yeah but but for those there's there you
can have way more right you can have how
many jewelry brands can the market hold
it could hold a ton because people are
going to have a bunch now if let's say
that
the industry newsletter a way to find
out what's going on in your industry um
how many is somebody if i'm in the waste
management industry how many of those am
i gonna read every week
i don't know two one or two right
probably one or two
okay industry drive is one now everybody
else is gonna fight for two and then if
you're not gonna go for waste management
you're gonna go for the next best nation
the next bit now industry has already
done 20 of these niches 30 of these
niches themselves um other people are
going to keep going for more and more of
these easter so you're going to get to
the less valuable niches or the ones
that are harder to require
subscribers for because you're all
fighting for that same
one or two spots and so um i think that
still somebody will win but it is way
harder than it was when this when the
word wasn't leaked that oh this
all these industry newsletters can be
that big that's crazy right
i think you're i think you're you you
you're giving people too much credit i
think that uh not that many people are
gonna get involved in this it's just so
much cooler when you're 22 you're like
you know like what's that one kid who
sells like sex chocolate like that's
just so much more fascinating what's
that called tabs
bad chocolate that makes you horny
that's so much cooler to like everyone
in la than
any of this
yeah do you get some of that included
when you rent the podcast studio space
you're in because it seems like it
should just be on the desktop
all right let's do another thing um
okay so i have one so here's another
kind of like
what i'll call boring idea hidden in
plain sight
aunt flow have you ever heard of this
company aunt flo
wait
is it aunt or aunt wait you say aunt
i say ah but it's also okay whatever all
right but not the insect yeah yeah your
mom's sister like yeah mom's yeah
exactly that time of the month is it's
the slang for that time of the month so
what these guys are doing or these gals
i don't know who's behind it
what they do is they go to a school or a
company and they say hey
uh you know your restrooms need to be a
little bit more female friendly here so
why don't we install this little like
case that's going to dispense tampons
and you know other kind of like
female menstrual cycle products any
anything that you can think of that goes
in that that that category
we're going to install this dispenser
and now you're just your place is going
to be more welcoming for um you know for
for females that are attending your
space so maybe girls at school or
university or in your company whatever
it is
and uh they just made it sexy so they
this these kind of hygiene products
already exist in bathrooms but they're
all like
we all know what they look like they're
that boring
you know silver box that looks like you
know if i open this up am i going to get
tools or a circuit breaker or like you
know
what am i going to get out of this thing
it's hard to hard to really say they
just made it look good and feel good and
like really nice packaging and design
and it's like it's like the tesla of
these things that are in the bathroom
wall
and
they're doing great so uh let me pull up
their numbers so they have i think 900
um
i don't know if i have all these numbers
correct but they have 900
orgs that are that are working with them
and basically you pay 300 bucks to
install the thing and then you pay like
1300 a year for 10 pound refills or pad
refills and so that's basically like 9
dollars for a school with 20 bathrooms
um
and think about that there's just a lot
of high schools like there there are
like you know i don't know 15 000 high
schools in the country that's just high
schools in the us then you have colleges
then you have companies
and they just made it like a sexy duty
product like the the logo looks cool the
box looks cool and now states are
requiring some schools like in
california colorado michigan that you
have to offer products for this
um and they do this like you know for
every 10 that we sell we donate one to a
menstruator in need like they have like
a whole thing around it it's like kind
of crazy
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
i uh last year i was pitched like three
different of these whenever we did that
vending machine pod i had so many people
reach out like i'm doing like smart
vending machine things or something like
that and a lot of them were or like
either tampons or like hygiene things or
or then they were like
healthy
food right and i looked at all the
numbers and most all of them were
horrible and the ones that were the best
they just sold coke and m m's like just
like normal like everyone wanted to do
this like one particular thing it was
like man america just wants coke and m
m's and that like crushed it what what
are the numbers on this one
on track for 10 million in 2022
um
so tripled from last year i don't know
when they started uh but they you know
now they're doing princeton university
every apple retail store offices like
google netflix disney twitter quicken
loans four year contract for all k
through 12 girls bathrooms in utah like
why am i not investing in this this is
such a defensible business like once you
get the contract they're not gonna have
again they're not gonna have two of
these at the bathroom and so like if
you're the brand that like looks good
and you can like sprint into market
something like this will get i think to
like 30 40 50 million in revenue for
sure quickly did they raise money i need
to chase this down uh yeah they're
they're raising money or they're they've
already raised somebody did you uh you
ever seen those dick pills at like the
counter at 7-eleven
can't say i had
yeah surely you have like it's like a
goat
it's like toad i forget what it is i
don't go into seven i don't leave the
house i definitely don't walk into
7-elevens well they're in these vending
machines they like it's like viagra or
something like that it's like some type
of like i actually have no idea what it
is but it's like a it's like a herbal
supplement and
your wife was telling me about this
gotta keep going
you could have that one and uh
and uh
you ever think
who makes those and what are their
business meetings like
you know what i mean is it just like a
bunch of dudes like serving monster
energy drink like sitting around like
you know what i mean have you seen that
uh everything that the whole meeting is
just done over xbox live
just like
yeah it's like we'll be uh serving
mountain dew and monster in order to get
this meeting started i've always
wondered what those things are like and
how you could be proud making that crap
this is way better than that it's not
the same thing but
i i've been thinking a lot about that
define a lot how much have you been
thinking about this well like like you
you know these um
uh
so we talked about uh milk boys and like
the send it thing or what is it called
full sense
and so many people reached out to me
after that and they go they make money
because they're sponsored by
this crypto poker thing called wrote
what's it called roblet you don't talk
about ruben yeah yeah and i saw this
video where they were talking about it
and it does like tens of millions
a month in sales like it's just like
astronomical just huge and i was
thinking i was like that's pretty cool
but i think like gambling like i'm okay
that it exists but it's just not for me
you know it's like what do i always say
like uh cornrows and sleeve tattoos it's
cool that other people have it not for
me
and
by the way that's catching on i did a
meeting with somebody and they i was
like oh nice chat they go yeah you know
what sam says
cornrows it's sleep tattoos it's not for
him but
he's got something yeah it's like wow
i i respect its right to exist but you
know it ain't for me but these like
these these businesses that do like
let's say gambling i'm like that's kind
of like
it's most likely a little bit shady it's
definitely not legal in america but
there's definitely it's related to
shadiness like it's in the same family
and i just wouldn't be proud doing that
on a d i wouldn't be proud doing that on
a daily basis you know what i mean
right and that's why i was thinking
about this
as somebody who spends a lot of time
gambling uh and has you know i ever tell
you in college how we used to drive from
north carolina where i went to school
down to south carolina a three-hour
drive that we would board a riverboat
casino that would that would sail into
international waters turn off the
engines and then let us gamble for four
hours and then it would drive back
and that's what i was doing as like a 20
year old
you know i was playing poker once and
the guy next to me
either fell asleep or died and i was
like oh my god like what am i doing here
why am i hanging out with these lowlifes
who are this guy is like this guy you
know like those people whose nails go so
long they start to like corkscrew like
this guy looked like that and i was like
this guy hasn't moved off this boat and
like a century and i shouldn't be here
but uh
couldn't resist
sleep or death i don't know i just left
the table i was like i don't i'm not
going to tap this guy and find out it's
like schrodinger's box is the cat dead
or not i didn't want to know so so i
just left but uh yeah lost a bunch of
money doing that so i don't know i like
gambling i think it's cool but also for
sure like it's not a business i would
start because i feel like
i don't want to start things where the
end is me in a netflix documentary it's
like what is the percent chance i have
to like be on the run
at some point in this business venture i
don't really want to flee the country
uh i'm not looking to like you know find
out that like you know we have a huge
amount of like
you know child pornography or you know
you know money laundering in my my app
it's like dude i'm not here for the
stress like i'm not trying to do all
that and i don't need to make like a
trillion dollars in a year doing this
like the state guys i i told the story
about them on the pod they do like 40
million a week in revenue no way they
issued i i think a how much is that
what's that like net revenue versus
gross
this is their take um they 40 a week
i heard they did a 800 million dollar
dividend
to their because they can't sell the
business
so i heard that they distributed like
800 million dollars
this could be this could be wrong but i
don't think it's wrong by like
more than 30
so
so that's pretty crazy
these things these guys these guys are
printed cash these are the guys who
bought that like they didn't know who
was behind it until some guy 40 million
dollars like a 36 million home yeah and
they were like how did this 26 year old
afford this
and they're like oh what where's the
source of your wealth it's like i own
steak.com did people just were based in
correct did people just message you
about what
and they told you that number
whenever we talk about any of this crap
my same friend who told me
yeah my same friend who told me about
them in the first place when i featured
them on here he was
telling me about like you know their
dividend and stuff like that rubet is
also big yeah these these things are
really big basically it's an online
casino and so like you take one of the
best business models in the world a
casino and you strip away the biggest
costs of it which are like you know the
the building the giant building and
having all this labor uh because all the
games are digital and there's the casino
is digital and now all you have left is
the marketing cost to acquire customers
and you can acquire customers from
around the globe in their bedroom and
they don't have to like fly to vegas to
do it right it's a kind of an amazing
model and like it's pretty obvious why
it's why it's huge but yeah you know
it's not for everybody um all right what
do you got okay i got i got another one
um
i got a framework and then i have
actually got two frames i have one
framework for i got a quick one and a
long one i'll do the quick one first
i realized this the other day i was like
um
yeah brian brian armstrong the founder
of coinbase went on uh lex freeman's
podcast yeah it was like so like what is
what is your startup advice what is your
advice for starting a startup it's like
it's one of those questions that as you
know as an entrepreneur you kind of hate
because you're like well it's like
saying you know like what is a good life
um so
but he gave an answer he kind of broke
it down he said well there's like
there's like two separate eras
pre-product market fit and post
and i was like that's i agree with that
100 percent like the things the way life
is pre and post is like important but
like
they need okay so for lex you got to
define like what is product market fit
and like
it's kind of hard to define product
market fit i don't know how you felt it
for the hustle because you kind of went
from events
to like i feel like we never had it
flashy blog posts to the newsletter you
don't think the newsletter had it
i mean we got to
we have 2.5 million people a day reading
so like i guess that there there's
definitely something there but like
people
when my friends talk about it they're
like oh man it just started working like
it never felt like it felt like a slog
the whole time it never felt like things
were just working i mean do you feel
that way at the milk road it just seems
like
like it i guess maybe technically
there's exponential growth because it's
growing like two or three hundred
percent a year but it wasn't like i
can't keep up
you know what i mean right
yeah so i'll tell you the frameworks
i've heard about this so one is uh
emmett who's the founder of twitch he
said this once and i i was like oh that
sounds right he goes
in a startup there's a big period where
it just feels like you're pushing a
giant boulder up a hill and you're
pushing and you're pushing and you're
pushing he's like and then there is a
point if it works
where all of a sudden you're not pushing
anymore the boulder starts to roll down
the other side of the hill and now you
have the opposite problem you're running
chasing to try to catch up with it
because it's rolling faster than you can
keep up with
and this is what other people say too
like you know your customers are like
demanding you know you can't you
basically you run out of inventory
people it's flying off the shelves like
these are the phrases people use to
describe this feeling it's where it
starts to feel like the market is
pulling you rather than pushing
and so have you ever heard that
i've experienced a little bit with our
d2c brand where we would but it's not
like it's not like this magical eden
where it never feels that way it never
feels hard again like that's kind of how
it sounds in my head it's like oh at
some point i'll stop pushing and it'll
start like rolling by itself and i'll
have to go ahead and chase it it's like
it's kind of like starts and stops of
that it's more like like a mountain
range where the hit you go up and then
down and then you climb the next
mountain it's a little higher and then
down then the next mountain and down
like that's how it feels like so for
example with with a with our e-commerce
company
um
okay getting the product made and
getting it to market and getting people
to first hear about our brand that was
pushing the boulder up but then
literally as soon as it like i remember
it went viral in like a facebook group
people started sharing it and like
enthusiasts of that category they
started sharing it and so we also i
remember like the third day we did like
three thousand dollars in sales without
like spending anything on marketing and
i was like where did that come from that
was awesome i didn't do anything and
like people started buying it and by our
second month we ran out of inventory um
and we had a we had a full our third
month our sales sucked because we just
had no inventory so that was like what
it felt like to pull
but then
to get the business to grow even more
well that's you know like that magic you
know sort of slowed down and sure people
were still telling their friends but i
wanted to hit a bigger goals now i had
to push again so it's been kind of
starts and stops with milk road i feel
like the growth is pushing the boulder
up a hill but then i look at some
numbers like the number of organic
people who like people who join because
they got referred the thing it's like a
really healthy percentage i'm like okay
so that means people are liking it if
they're sharing with friends
and um the feedback like the replies we
get are not just like oh that was a good
one today it's like
they like they're using our own language
and sense of humor it's like they want
to be friends with us they're like
they're like oh you know the milk was so
hot this morning it turned into butter
and like you know it's like who said who
like goes into a product uses it that
day and then comes up with a funny
review just because you kind of want to
be boys with the people who are making
it like that's that shows that they
really care in some way and we get like
hundreds of those a day so so that shows
me it's working but still to grow and
fill the revenue slots like that feels
like a slog like that doesn't feel easy
that feels like very very difficult
so um so yeah i i don't have a good
answer i've seen it firsthand with two
different people so the first is i used
to share this office uh called founders
dojo you know you it was uh dave
grossblatt a bunch of us when i was
starting the company uh the hustle and
there was these two guys that were like
the most stereotypical like silicon
valley nerds it was like a skinny indian
dude and then this white guy that looked
like this jock he was like really good
looking jock but he was like the
dorkiest dude ever and they were
partners and it was a hilarious com
combination
and
they created this technology that would
basically i have no idea why they wanted
to create this technology it's honestly
kind of pointless but basically it would
crawl the internet
and it would find the most shared and
most popular hd gifs gifs whatever on
the internet that day and they built
this thing and then they would spend
hours
making the search so if you just typed
in one letter
it would autofill with like things that
you could search like gifs like if you
typed in like the word c would autofill
cats and then like the search would just
pop up and i remember we'd be like
staring at the computer with them just
saying like look how much faster it is
it was like you can't even tell like you
know how much faster it was from the
previous time but they were nerded out
over this and they launched this thing
and it did okay did okay it did okay and
then one day we get into the office and
they've stayed there all night
and they slept underneath the table
their desk i remember and i remember
like dave had bought them pizza because
like they were working the whole time
and we were like what's going on raj
like why is this why is this happening
and their website was called the worst
drug which is pretty hilarious it's
called the worst drug dot tv i think
basically some porn guys got a hold of
it and
the it like they he they somehow i don't
know how it worked but the most shared
gifts on the web
are almost all porn and so they like
disabled like that not safer work
feature and it was all porn and we get
to the office and they had this fancy
setup like this a huge monitor and it
was the highest def porn you i've ever
seen and you click like space and it
would autofill with like a new porn
shift and and like
at first
i used this by the way i remember seeing
it it went viral like in 2014 or
something it was like somebody shared it
in our irc they're like this is a crazy
website and it was like full screen hd
immediate like porn and you're like whoa
you touch any key and it just reloads
another one instantaneously i was like
whoa what's going on it was like every
time before tick tock so basically there
was like eight of us
eight guys and like we were gathered
around this computer and at first we
were like shocked it was like hardcore
porn like shock shocking porn that would
go viral or like people like click on
and like the whole porn thing we got
past it and then we were like wow that's
really high def look at that like oh if
you click space like it really it loads
so fast and there were just eight of us
like gather around us and tim wester
just see the hair on his thigh yeah it
was crazy it was disgusting and tim
westergen and his assistant i forget her
name but they i was supposed to
interview them in preparation because
they were speaking at hustlecon and i
told them to come to the office and they
walked into the founders
pandora yeah the founder of pandora they
walk into the office
and there's eight of us gathered around
this screen just like staring intensely
at this point like wow good good job raj
like when you type and see it really
autofills like really quickly like you
know like this is amazing
and they walk in and i'm like oh hey
what's going on you guys want to see
something check out this technology like
it was
and they had
uh like millions of people a day coming
to the website overnight and they slept
there at the office for weeks trying to
like you know do something with the
server to keep up with the traffic and
like increase the speed just a little
bit and eventually something happened
where like someone in romania offered to
buy it and they flew there and it turns
out that it was like some gangsters and
then they like all had like guns on them
and they came back and it was like a
whole ordeal but that's the one time
that i really saw product market fit
work
so i've heard stories like that like uh
when instagram launched it was kind of
the same thing they like they launched
it they put it out in the wild you know
first hours pretty slow or whatever the
guys kind of go to sleep they wake up
and like or like not even they go sleep
it was like late at night and it was
early in the morning in japan and the
app had started to go viral in japan and
so they were like dude what are all
these like why are there only pictures
of tea and it's like oh this is in japan
people are having tea in the morning and
they're taking instagram pictures of it
and they had like 25 000 people
downloaded that first or second day
and the server is like you know
basically melting and like pretty
quickly the only problem became how do
we get more server capacity it's like oh
you you stop thinking about features you
stop thinking about the logo you stop
thinking about names you stop thinking
about hiring it's like all i think about
is like how do i add more servers and so
actually i started to realize that there
is there's a test
the simplest test a product market fit
because people have tried to come up
with these tests before in fact
um there's a kind of famous silicon
valley one which is you survey your
users um
this thing which is if our product went
away if you could no longer use our
product how would you feel very
disappointed somewhat disappointed or
not disappointed and the idea was if 40
or more say very disappointed you have
product market fit sounds good in theory
it's sort of like yeah it's like it's
like astrology it's like giving you a
way to have this answer to this like
mystical question
and uh mark andreessen said this thing
he goes part of work fit is like sex if
you if you're asking if you have it
you're not having it and like you know i
think that's more
real uh which is like there isn't this
40 survey number you can't survey your
way to finding out you'll know because
it kind of hits you like a punch in the
face and so what i've seen is that the
people who really have it like
their thing is going to go supernova
they only care about two things
those two things are if it's a tech
product hiring more servers and if it's
any kind of product hiring customer
customer support people
and if any time i meet a founder now
who's like yeah dude i just really you
know any good like customer support
people like where do i find more support
people or like hey do you know how i can
get like aws credits i'm like running up
a crazy bill i'm like
uh let me invest first and then also yes
let me help you with that because i know
when that happens that is almost the
truest sign of product market fit it is
the survey you don't need to go do with
your customers when a founder stops
thinking about features stops thinking
about like future plans and marketing
and you know company culture and
everything else and they're like
dude the [__] is melting so i asked
michael birch who was my my former boss
and then became my investor at my uh
idea lab and you know michael had
basically sold bibo for 850 million
dollars and i wanted to know like
and he had struggled before that for
three three and a half years to like
make something work
and so i asked him i was like you know
what was it like kind of
before before and like you know when the
turning point happened like did you were
you just feeling like so good once once
it clearly started to work
he was like
well he kind of described the boulder
pushing up the hill thing he's like well
before when i was like i quit my job we
had two kids and a third on the way we
had mortgaged our house and like i had
told my wife give me six months to try
this and now i was three years in and i
still hadn't figured out anything that
worked but i felt like i was getting
closer and closer he's like
that was hard i felt like i was pushing
the boulder up the hill then with bibo
we like i finally put together all the
pieces i knew that social networking was
a good product like a good category like
this before facebook like i knew that
social networking was going to be big
people were going to talk to other
people on the internet they were gonna
have profiles and comment on each
other's pages i just felt like that was
true
and then i knew how to grow it which was
like these viral like kind of fill in
your profile quizzes and share it with
your friends i knew how to grow it and
like
so i i i launched the thing he goes in
nine days we had a million users and
he's like back then a million users was
like so huge on the internet
he's like he's like you know nine days
later none of them came back i had a
retention problem but he's like i knew
that i had like something that could
light fire so i turned it off i started
working on the retention to like give
you a reason to come back every day he's
like i knew this is gonna work he's like
and then when it worked he's like i
didn't feel like this immense joy like
yay i finally overcame it he's like i
felt even more
pressure he's like
dude now
this is actually you finally did it
don't eff this up like this can actually
be valuable
don't mess this up he's like that became
a whole new level of pressure and like
burden that i felt and he's like i
worked so hard and i think after they
sold like what are four years in or
something like that i think he had like
major heart surgery like five months
later because he had been like so
working so hard and under so much stress
and pressure that whole time i'm sure
that could contribute to something like
that but when he described that i was
like okay so i've never felt that like
i've never felt anything that you just
described that means i've never felt the
like the violent version of product
market fit when that like a billion
dollar company feels so what did brian
uh he didn't say what it feels he didn't
define it as much he was just he had
said basically some something along the
lines of
you know um
you know you're making something that
people want and um you know that you
know there's like you know whatever true
to band for he says something sort of
general like that but i've been thinking
about how do you know because that's so
general that you're going to be
optimistic and think you have it when
you don't because god it would feel so
good to have it and man it really sucks
to not have it so you're always kind of
like squinting and looking for these
like this evidence and what brian said
was he goes act he goes my lucky thing
was i wasn't a big analyzer or a big
thinker i was just like action produces
information so i would just do a thing
and i'd produce some information like oh
people want this or they don't want this
or they want it but there's something
wrong with it uh like the the bebo thing
with oh they it grew but they didn't
stick around okay but that produced
information that first nine days
produced a lot of information and so
he's like
okay i built this wrong but now i know
what's wrong with it so let me do
another round and like he's like
actually produces information so as a
founder like just focus on the action
part and like
it'll either hit for you or it won't but
like action is really the only way
you're gonna get to it and like you know
smart action meaning you take action
then you sort of like accurately assess
what's working and what's not so that
you're not taking blind action have you
ever thought about the logistics of that
though so
coinbase uh there was this article a
couple years ago written about them and
when they were when i think in
18 or 19 when like the first cycle was
happening and they're saying how like
they've torn down walls at their office
like
just because they don't have enough
space and like they people need to be in
the same room to like shout at one
another and then they're like we're also
just taking meetings uh in the park i
forget where their office was but it was
where near where you and i lived in san
francisco and they'd be like yeah we're
taking meetings in the park because
there's just physically not enough space
and if you think about the logistics of
it you basically have this idea in this
small thing in 2015 or 16 or whatever
and so right now they're at i think 4
000 employees which means they've
probably hired
six or seven thousand if you account for
turnover and if there's you know 360
days in a year or whatever it is 350
days a year that's like you're basically
adding 10 to 20 people a day in head
count every single day for three years
it's pretty wild that's wild right in
order to add
10 or 30 people a day whatever you and
that's not even like that much compared
to like a facebook or google but
like does it that means that you got to
talk to
yeah
five times ten times more yeah yeah it's
he says
he goes we have i think he said 3 000
people now he goes but and i he's like i
personally i think was involved in the
hiring of maybe the first like i forgot
what he said like 300 to 500. he's like
but then to hire those 300 500 i had to
talk to
maybe three or five thousand people so
he's like so i've done a lot of
interviewing now and i have a good idea
like if you think about the interview
he's like i got totally burnt out from
it if you just think like all right how
are we gonna get everyone a laptop
or um how do we like make everything
breaks
everything breaks it's crazy have you
ever experienced that firsthand
not that but i i've heard stories again
i've heard stories and that's how i know
i didn't have broadband even when i
thought i had it and growth is happening
i've only ever felt it one time with
blab when our servers kept melting down
and it wasn't during a period where we
went from about zero to two million
users
in like a
six month period and like we just kept
like our vendors servers were going down
then we're like [__] what do we do like
dude
how's talkbox going down how is
cloudflare you know going down what's
going on here like it was like and we
were also getting ddos attacked and [__]
like that but but basically yeah it was
that's the only time i sort of felt it
but that was like you know a very brief
window of time the
there's this guy dan rose i don't know
if you follow him on twitter he was like
a very yeah number three number three
guys facebook or something yeah he was
very early at amazon maybe like first 50
or 100 people
uh i was like something like that but he
was early early days like he was around
when the dot-com bust happened right so
99 2000 2001 time period then he went to
facebook and he was he ended up being
like the number three guy at facebook
behind zuck and cheryl
and um so anyways he shares these war
stories from the from back then he says
these things that again you don't feel
unless you're building one of these like
you know thunder lizard type companies
that are just like these godzilla's and
he's like yeah at amazon he's like we
used to just do meetings in the
stairwell because there was just like we
ran out of desk space we were starting
two people at every desk that didn't
even work i was just working out of a
stairwell for like a three-month period
i think just imagine like he's like yeah
i just took my laptop i just sat there
on the top stair and i was just like
somebody would be walking by and be like
hey hey uh for that thing we're
launching tomorrow like can we and then
i just walk with them down the stairs
while we talk and that was our meeting
and so he shares these stories about
like what it was like his twitter follow
his twitter is a good follower for sure
did i ever tell you uh
did i ever tell you about the airbnb
cafeteria
no
so
uh when sarah my wife works there and i
used to go to the office because my
office was right next door to it for
dinner time all the time basically they
had this beautiful office and every
office or meeting room is made to look
like a popular airbnb like you know
thing you could rent and it's like this
beautiful office you know brian and joe
they're like designers so every and
everything like in their office looks
exactly like that
and their cafeteria can you know seat
three or feed three thousand people or
whatever however many people they have
there and their whole shtick was every
single item
was made there at the office so the red
bull they had like airbnb bowl the
ketchup the mayonnaise made right there
the trail mix like they made they made
everything 100
except for the beer i think that's the
only thing that they didn't make but
besides that if you consumed it it's
like they didn't have doritos you
couldn't get a coke in that office it
was all made right there on the spot and
i remember thinking like this company
just that in itself is like a pretty
amazing feat and that's not even close
to being like their thing you know what
i mean yeah that's exactly that's like
that's not that's not their thing this
is logistics you know that's their
version of lunch yeah it's just table
stakes to get people to work there and i
remember like thinking like how on earth
do you pull that off because like just
literally five years ago or maybe three
years ago i had interviewed there and it
was
200 people
and it was like an okay office but it it
that that i remember seeing that and i
was like this is just amazing this is
this is absolutely ridiculous
i had the same experience i went to um
zynga's office back when zingo was like
you know still airbnb used to share an
office with them i believe by the way i
went to that zing office as well
and that office is crazy first you walk
in and there's like a tunnel to enter
like you remember that tunnel the light
the lit up tunnel so it's like you walk
in it's an led tunnel so you feel like
you're entering a special you feel like
you're entering a spaceship of some kind
or like you know you're walking out into
a stadium
and then there's just dogs everywhere i
was like oh well do people have
allergies here how's this allowed to say
oh yeah i don't know we're just it's
like this free free land and i met uh we
met the chef this guy matt um matthew i
think it's a do trumbull what's his name
sounds like a chef name and so he was
like yeah let me give you a tour and so
he was the one who brought us into the
office i was like okay uh he said yeah
i'll give you like the kitchen tour and
i was like okay cool this will take like
you know two minutes and then we'll go
see the other thing and like the kitchen
tour took an hour because it was the
exact same thing he goes
he goes so this is our staff he goes
everything that you eat here is made on
premise and i was like okay he's like
see that like i was like you guys have
like a he's like you wanted to drink i
was like yeah i'll take like a sparkling
water or whatever he's like cool it's on
tap here and it was their fizzy water i
was like you make your own fizzy water
he's like yeah we make our own seltzer
ciders beers they made everything he's
like um yeah this like you know the
salad here like we grow all the like we
have a micro farm on the roof that's
crazy and so like this mushroom was
grown here this like arugula is grown
here it's all a circular system i was
like what and then he's like um
i was like but what about the you don't
have like animals for like a you know
he's like no no we do get animals we get
the full animal so he opens up the
walk-in fridge and there's just cow
cows hanging upside down full cows and i
was like what is this and he's like yeah
we break down the entire carcass and we
like you know use every bit of it for
our things i was like you and what army
dude he's like oh we have 45 people and
our chef is crazy executive i'm the
executive chef and we have 45 people on
our team
i was like you have i don't have 45
people in my company you have 45 people
on the lunch team and i was like this is
just absurd it was insane and i was like
wow the arms race for like you know
pampering tech tech things like building
this like culture of you're building
something special was
you know kind of amazing to be honest it
was really amazing i i was blown away by
that i have cows on my at my ranch on my
airbnb property
and i've we have like
18 of them or something like that and
i've and you know they butcher them so
they like every year they send away like
four or five and then well i see the new
ones being born
and i thought it'd be cool to get a
freezer out there and you like paid 20
bucks and you could get a steak and be
like yeah this cow is you know like the
mother of the one that you see right in
front of y'all like like the uh you know
because you could sit on the porch and
like watch the cows would come up that's
too sad for me and uh it was too sad for
me i couldn't do it i need like distance
from it i need to like
ignorance is bliss for me when it comes
to eating me yeah i didn't end up doing
it because i was like this is just tmi i
can't handle it because i like i see
these guys playing and i get to know him
and they get to know me and i was like
oh [__] right i'm not nearly as tough as
i thought
i know all right should we wrap it or
because there yeah like are you paying
by the minute now uh your surcharge your
your studio because i'm free here in my
studio
um yeah well uh you know ben's still
getting used to like the logistics of
this so uh i'll just leave it at that
but i think i think our time is up what
do you think you are are you inspired
now to look better or you still don't
give a [__]
i'm very inspired the inspiration isn't
the problem the uh
the uh skill to do it is the problem to
like upgrade my own space
that's gonna give it's gonna like do it
do you use that room for anything
i use it for for this and my wife works
out of here too so but but we can use it
for however it's an office though right
it's like
well like just like it'll look like a
cnn newsroom just have her in the
background like working
like it'll look fine you just make it
look a little pretty they'll put some of
this crap on there dude send them i'm
open to it the door's open ring the
doorbell
all right well i guess that's the pod
we'll see if this actually
changes anything but it might
[Music]
you